es la ciudad a la que muchos pretenden
llegar
por Sudán
una posible ruta de escape para huir de
la guerra en curso con muchos hoteles
copados algunos acampan en los muelles
todos se esperan conseguir un tiquete
para salir del país
cuando llega un barco a la gente le
sellan el pasaporte y se va estamos
luchando
el proceso de evacuación es muy
complicado algunas personas llevan aquí
cinco seis o incluso 10 días
cuatro aviones cargados de alimentos y
suministros médicos aterrizaron el
viernes en la ciudad costera
sin embargo la entrega de ayuda No ha
sido fácil el reto es como hacer llegar
estos suministros a donde se necesitan y
a las instalaciones sanitarias para
salvar las vidas de los pacientes
heridos tenemos que hacer al mismo
tiempo tanto a nivel superior desde el
nivel más alto posible presionando a las
partes combatientes pero lo más
importante para mí ahora operativamente
es hacerlo con el nivel local para
conseguir realmente el acceso ante el
saqueo de los kombuches Naciones Unidas
ha exigido al ejército regular y el
grupo paramilitar fuerzas de acción
rápida que garanticen el paso seguro de
la ayuda a pesar del alto al fuego los
combates continúan y la ONU advierte que
860.000 personas podrían verse obligadas
a huir de Sudán Mientras tanto Al otro
lado del mar Rojo ambos bandos
enfrentados llegaron a la ciudad Saudita
de lleda para discutir las condiciones
de una posible tregua